This is absolutely disgusting what I'm about
to play for you, but it does remind us about
the people that Donald Trump had around him
for so long.
Donald Trump's longtime adviser and policy
guy, Steve Bannon, Steve Bannon at one point
sat in on the National Security Council meetings,
has called for the beheading of Dr. Anthony
Fauci and of FBI Director Christopher Wray.
This was brought to my attention during a
live stream yesterday.
I thought I was being baited.
I thought somebody is pulling my leg.
There is no way in hell that Steve Bannon
said we should behead Dr. Anthony Fauci.
But he did.
He said it.
And Steve Bannon has since been banned from
Twitter.
I believe his show has been banned from YouTube,
although that's less clear at this point.
Take a look at this.
That's a second term.
Second term kicks off with FINRA fined Falchi.
Now, I actually want to go a step further,
but I believe the president is a kindhearted
man and a good man.
I'd actually like to go back to the old times
of Tudor, England.
I'd put the heads on pikes, right.
I'd put them at the two corners of the White
House as a warning to federal bureaucrats
you to get with the program are you're gone
time to stop playing games, blow it all out.
But put Rick Grenell today as the interim
head of the FBI.
That'll that'll light some.
That'll light him up.
Right.
You know what, Steve?
Just yesterday, there was the anniversary
of the hanging of two Tories in Philadelphia.
These were Quaker businessmen who had cohabited,
if you will, with the British while they were
occupying Philadelphia.
These people were hung.
This is what we used to do to traitors.
That's how you won the revolution.
Nobody wants to talk about revolution.
Wasn't some sort of garden party, right?
Was not was a civil war.
It was a civil war.
Also in the revolution, you put their heads
on pikes while you've got to remove their
heads.
In order to do that, Steve Bannon is saying
behead Anthony Fauci as well as the FBI director.
We behead doctors.
First of all, we behead anybody.
But you're going after doctors.
Doctors trying to deal with the pandemic are
the central target of your ire.
That's what we're doing in the United States.
And a CNN business is reporting Twitter permanently
suspended the account belonging to Steve Bannon
after he made the suggestion he posted it
in a video.
The video post was made to Facebook, YouTube
and various Twitter accounts.
This is what we're talking about when we talk
about al-Qaida.
OK, a political party.
Biden says that you need a political party
in control that says federal employees who
don't do what they want get executed and they
also want to believe that they are not disgusting
fascists.
We've got a Republican president refusing
to commit to a peaceful transfer of power,
insisting the election is rigged.
Calling on racist armed supporters to stand
by Ben and talks like the Taliban and indeed
right wing extremists.
As I've been pointing out for a long time,
they have a lot in common with the Taliban.
It's just a different religion under which
they claim this outrageous fascistic authoritarianism.
And remember, Steve Bannon has a federal indictment
against him.
He is an alleged coconspirator, along with
many other Republican figures close to Donald
Trump.
And it seems to me that the consequences should
be a little more severe, severe than being
banned from Twitter and this.
I mean, listen, Foushee already has full time
security.
I'm sure that the FBI director has full time
It's not about them, but it is about, again,
this term, stochastic terrorism in the possibility,
the ability that it has to generate real world
violence.
And in the middle of all of this, you have
a president whose son is tweeting, as we talked
about earlier, we need to go to total war.
Total war is what they are claiming.
And by the way, there's still a pandemic.
And I want to talk about that a little bit.